all right drew well you know we've
talked about uh singles are
raring to go after lockdown you know you
are well now the new york post
reports that they're already at it and
the hottest new club
is the vaccine line people are finding
dates while they're getting their shots
the article reported that one woman said
her 70 year old mom
got asked out in the vaccine line get it
girl apparently there's a lot of
flirting going on and now dating sites
like coffee meets bagel
have you heard of that one oh yeah yeah
they will they actually let you
advertise your vac status to attract a
mate
which i think more dating apps are going
to do right i think
you know we've all been locked down
forever if it's been 14 months since
you've been touched by somebody else you
look at them
you're safe you're good it's on let's go
well let everybody bloom yes please
well people are frisky for pfizer but
they're also getting frisky with their
home decor
and we've been cooped up so long it
inspired a playful new design trend
vogue says that this year it's all about
the squiggle
the wubble and the blob check out these
photos
i find this so joyous i love the cuts
and
angles designers are working more with
fun surprising shapes and people are
leaning away from the clean predictable
lines
of mid-century modern and looking for
something more whimsical
and playful i mean i love a blob ross
yeah do you love a blob ross ross uh i
do drew
i think square is so square right and it
is fun to incorporate just a little bit
of whimsy have some fun
during uh lockdown i actually redid the
tiles
in my backsplash in palm springs and
look that's the backsplash
in my kitchen and so it's just a little
a little space but with something
whimsical
totally change the vibe massively
transformational you don't have to
do a whole room over or go crazy or
spend a lot of money or be overwhelmed
by it
just start with an object and then you
might use that as the inspiration
in itself and so i just love this story
and i love everything designed your
tournament yeah have some fun people go
nuts oh and drew i have a good story for
you you know your favorite cozy boot
just got climate friendly pop sugar
reports that
ugg has released their plant power
collection
a carbon neutral line of shoes made with
renewable
plant materials they've got fluff sugar
sole sandal
it's made with renewable sugar cane and
the numeral
natural boot made of hemp and both of
these
uh the crops actually absorb co2 from
the air
and there's another one the heavier
rubber boot is made of latex that's
harvested from
live rubber trees really that's true
i have to say um my daughter olive
has like the red version of these
they're a little shorter so it's almost
like
if it got a haircut yes and these are
super on trend i mean can you not see
like a kendall jenner throwing one of
these on and it becomes the hottest shoe
on the planet
and a heartbeat and you know they have
this huge ugg store
in manhattan on fifth avenue and we
talked about how we wanted to go in
yes i did no i did and i went in and i
you know you think you know uggs right
um
but you don't they are changing the game
and i kind of wanted
everything this is a little um
big bird for me the color it's muppety
yeah
but yes i'm not convinced that's a bad
thing though don't you want to wear that
around the house
again one it girl wears it and it's
going to be the hottest trend and i
really do
love their new straps with their
branding um
i will say this thank you ugg thank you
so much for showing what can be done
environmentally i'm so grateful
any company out there that's doing it
different and realizing a new way
is how we're going to make it here on
this planet so my gratitude agree
check this story out because i think
it's been a really feel-good show
there is a national mom-and-pop business
owners day
and we have a great story from the denim
springs louisiana
that shows why mom and pop shops are so
important to our communities
sunny skies reports that the owners of
poppy's fajita factory
have devised an easy way for customers
to help
the hungry and when you pay for your
meal you can buy a meal for someone else
at the very same time a coupon is
printed out and tacked to the wall
and anyone who needs it can take one of
those coupons as a voucher
and get a hot meal it's beautiful simple
easy way to take care of the people
around you
and i hope this practice spreads far and
wide saving the planet
and saving each other absolutely get
your fajita and give someone a free heda
that's right exactly right rossi i think
we have really good news today
we did